the umbrella Academy's mind and
time-bending finale pays off multiple
plot threads that have been quietly
simmering in the background and drops a
ton of new revelations that are going to
have major implications moving forward
there is no shortage of material here to
impac and discuss perhaps the most
cryptic scene of all in the umbrella
academies season finale comes right at
the beginning of the episode it opens
with a flashback a still-living Reginald
Hargreaves is confronting a woman who
seems to be his lover as she dies of an
unnamed illness outside dozens of
otherworldly spaceships are exiting the
atmosphere indicating that this strange
world is experiencing its last moments
though never directly stated we can
assume from this that Reginald
Hargreaves is an alien something which
is also briefly stated in the comics but
never explore deeper also there is one
final inexplicable element before
Reginald leaves his homeworld for Earth
he opens a jar that releases dozens of
tiny Firefly like things which fly up
into the air and vanish no explanation
is given but this is undeniably setting
up something all we have now a tinfoil
hat theories like the idea that there
were 43 of those fireflies and these are
responsible for the 43 earth women who
gave birth to the superpower children in
the first episode if this is the case it
could mean the Hargreaves created the
children as a way of giving the earth
someone to protect it as a way of
atoning for failing to protect his own
homeworld this is pure speculation of
course but it would explain why
Hargreaves was so interested in adopting
as many of these super kids as possible
once the flashback is over we're back in
the present where things are not going
well for what remains of the Hargreaves
family the virus discovered she has
ability to transform ambient sound into
deadly force
after getting understandably upset at
her family for intentionally or
unintentionally belittling her and
deceiving her about her powers
throughout her entire life she
reflexively lashes out gravely wounding
Allison and killing several others up
and so now the rest of the team has been
trying to figure out what's going to
cause the end of the world but now they
realize the source of the apocalypse is
Guerin to be Vanya Carol Jenkins was the
cosmic he was the fuse Vanya is the bomb
Vanya causes the apocalypse
you see Vanya st. Loup V M Chamber
Orchestra has a performance later that
day in the icarus theater and with her
new sound manipulation powers going out
of control this concert has a potential
to end the world
midway through the episode a bunch of
new assault rifle wielding buddies and
red gas masks show up and start trying
to kill our heroes it's never stated
especially where they came from or who
they're working for
but if you are paying close attention
earlier in the season you should
recognize them instantly in episode 6
they same gas masks are hanging up in
the background as the handler is giving
number 5 a tour of the time travel
enforcement Bureau known as the
Commission so much like hazel char-char
in the hit squad that attacks number 5
at the end of the first episode the men
in gas masks are additional agents and
service to the Commission the late
arrival of these masked goons indicate
that we possibly haven't seen the full
array of the different types of agents
and resources that the Commission has
that is suppose --all
the level of threat they're going to be
sending moving forward will likely just
escalate from here early in this episode
it seems hazel might be back to working
for the wrong side the handler tells him
and charge Charla if they can protect
Vanya until the apocalypse hits they'll
both be forgiven for their previous
transgressions hazel agrees at first but
on the way to the icarus theater things
take a dramatic turn when he
purposefully crashes his car in an
attempt to kill cha-cha and escape the
assignment after leaving Church off a
dead hazel returns to the handlers hotel
room to free his girlfriend Agnes but
the handler stands in his way we're
expecting another dramatic conversation
in witch hazel and the handler debate
the merits of their respective
worldviews births hazel skips his parts
and just shoots her in the head you
might think that this means as troubles
are over
but when number 5 threatened to do the
same thing to the handler in episode 5
she warned I'll just be replaced
I'm but a small cog in a machine even
though she acts like the one directing
the entire Commission at the handless
death would probably only mean things
will get worse for our heroes fingers
crossed we'll finally get a chance to
meet the big boss from the comic book an
evil sentient goldfish in a robot body
by the name of Carmichael during the
final battle in the icarus theater
Welles exhibits a new power for the
first time channeling the spirits of his
dead brother Ben who were peers in the
middle of the room in a ghostly blue
form this manifestation of Ben is
however quite corporeal as he is able to
use the super powers he had when he was
alive to create a massive super-strong
tentacles to tend to kill the squad of
Commission agents attacking his siblings
Klaus is able to achieve this new level
of
power because he's managed to stay sober
for a while now which seems to have
opened the doors to power beyond just
communicating with the dead if you
remain sober into season 2 we could see
Klaus use telekinesis and levitation a
pair of powers he has in the comics but
lacks in the show it's also likely that
Klaus has increased ability to channel
Ben into the physical world means that
the second season will give us much more
fan who will also finally get a chance
to interact with other members of the
family when Diego confronts Church are
at the icarus it looks as though he'll
finally be able to have his vengeance
over the death of his friend detective
Eudora patch at the end of the fight
however when Diego has charged Herod as
mercy he ends up sparing her life if you
were confused as to why this is actually
a combination of his journey throughout
the season even before he became
consumed with his quest for vengeance
Diego was always one of the morally
murkier Hargreaves children the one
thing that always kept him from going
off the deep end however was his
friendship with patch when Diego finally
gets the chance to kill charger he can't
help but imagine what patch would think
of him now he remembers a conversation
with five that he had in episode 9 from
patch would you like about her she
believed in people she always saw the
good inside Diego realizes that perhaps
there was some good inside char as well
even if she herself hadn't realized it
yes and he decides to leave her alive so
maybe she can also get a chance to find
it someday does this mean that the AYGO
is going to be less broody in the future
probably not but it's a start one of the
biggest turning points in the Umbrella
Academy season one finale comes when
Alison has to decide whether or not
Vanya is beyond saving up and so now
alison has always advocated attempting
to reason with her but when Vanya is
about to kill not just a for hargreaves
boys but also possibly the entire world
Alison realizes that she might need to
be put down for good
in the comics Vanya actually does get
shot in the head at this moment but as
5u pulls the trigger NOS allison the
comics version of Vanya ends up
surviving the injury but she's paralyzed
and suffers memory loss in the show
however allison opts for another way
placing the gun right beside Vanya's
head and firing a sound that close to
Vanya's ear is enough to break her
concentration long enough for the
Hargreaves poised to escape even though
she falls unconscious all the energy
Vanya has been gathering up has to go
somewhere as she passes out an enormous
beam of white light erupts out of her
chest and flies into space impacting on
the full moon above then as the entire
moon starts to glow red hot it suddenly
becomes very clear how the world is
supposed to end as they say shoot for
the moon as pieces of the Moon rain down
from the heavens our hero's only have a
few moments to do something to save the
world how do they manage it
well they don't number-5 makes them all
gather together so they can travel back
in time to try and prevent the
apocalypse that's an earlier juncture
and can have a way out of here you gotta
trust me on this
the long-term consequences on Vanya
aren't clear since she passes out
immediately and doesn't wake up before
the end of the episode but it's possible
she's suffered hearing damage that would
certainly make her career as a violinist
more difficult and add an unexpected
wrinkle to her carrot salad the ability
to control sound we can assume that very
few people survive the end of the world
outside of our main seven heroes if you
can count Bennis surviving thatis most
of the other names characters were dead
already
including Pogo mom Leonard and the
handler but what about hazel and cha-cha
it's a blink in your missing moments but
a second before the blast hits hazel and
agnes they've disappeared a flash of
blue light this implies they stole a
briefcase one of the Commission's
time-travel devices from the handler
after killing her we don't know where
hazel and Magnus troubled - but we can
assume we haven't seen the last of them
jojo's faith is far more grim despite
technically succeeding at a final
assignment of keeping Vanya Hargreaves
of life we see that in her final moments
she is trying and failing to contact HQ
from a payphone this could be Bakr's as
hazel predicted the Commission never
intended to rescue them from the
apocalypse or it could simply be because
the handler is dead and there's no one
to receive her call either way we
unfortunately have to say Tata to ChaCha
but since hazel and cha-cha have had
long and illustrious careers as
time-traveling
sus ins it's possible that the
Hargreaves will run into these two again
it's an earlier point in their lives
when the pair were still cold-blooded
killers nothing can mess with the
character art quite like time travel men
did say time travel could came to him
late the mind as the Hargreaves are
preparing to travel back in time they
appear for a moment to be de-aged back
to how they looked as teenagers is it
possible that this is just supposed to
be a cool artsy way to end the season a
symbolic representation of how the
Hargreaves have finally been reunited
together as a family like back when they
were children but it's also possible
that this moment is meant to be taken
very literally remember that number five
himself didn't eyes look 13 he used to
be a 58 year old man but his age has
reset back to 13 as an unintended side
effect of the method he used to
time-travel if five is setting his
siblings back using the same method it's
possible that they'll be the age the
same way he was from what we've seen of
five struggles for this situation
getting stuck in a body that's a wrong
age it's not an easy problem to fix in a
rough couple of days if it does indeed
happen though than a big conflict for
the coming season we'll probably be the
team trying to find a way to return to
adulthood
there might be another side effect to
this however and this more an
ambiguously positive since Ben's ghost
is also hitching a ride if everything
about these characters is reversing to
health things well and they were teens
it's possible that he might not just be
returned to youth but back to life as
well check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the bail so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]